the New York Times is no longer verified
that's right so it will not come up in
verified mentions they're they're you
know they claim to have 54.9 million
followers as you see there their tweets
barely get a thousand retweets which
means that basically 54.9 million people
ignore everything that they say and uh
here's Elon Musk on on just that he
wrote the real tragedy of the New York
Times is that their propaganda isn't
even interesting so people are being red
pilled right that's what's happening
right in front of our faces and again we
just you can't take it as a win like ah
look it's all great because the machine
is never going to stop they will try to
do to Ron DeSantis what they're doing to
Donald Trump and we have to defend I
would say we have to give everything we
can to defend Donald Trump from this
madness because as he has pointed out it
will come for him now but he's just the
one standing in the way eventually it'll
come from everybody I think we have to
defend a guy like Ron DeSantis when it
comes to the right policies
and how about this you have to defend
your kids you have to defend the people
in your local community and everything
else uh because they are just not going
to stop we got a little more for you
here uh this is Joe Rogan he had Michael
schellenberger on again schellenberger
of course is the a lifelong Lefty
liberal I've had him on the show a
couple times uh he is one of the guys
who did the original Twitter files uh
they started talking about Elon and
truth and conspiracy theories and why
Twitter sort of is an important place
now to get some of this stuff cleaned up
we were talking about this last night
that you know when I was texting Elon
about all this stuff he he was like he's
hilarious he's like turns out all the
conspiracy theories were true LOL
[Laughter]
funny he's so casual yeah
I'm like tickling the whole thing being
like this is care I guess having 200
billion dollars really puts a nice
cushion on like the repercussions for
whatever the you do other than him
getting assassinated and he has publicly
stated that I'm not suicidal and I think
he's legitimately concerned like that
could be something that happens to him
his security details amazing it should
be yeah yeah it should be Beyond me yeah
he's had a Iron Man Garden even
better than your security
stop after this interview
look Rogan has got the biggest podcast
on the planet millions and millions of
people listening to each week and
millions and millions of people are
listening to Elon Musk and they're on
the same side of this thing Elon Musk
who is a lifelong Democrat has said he
would vote for Ron DeSantis and it's not
just about the political part of this it
is that truth as I always say has been a
time release pill and enough of us are
waking up we just got to keep waking up
more people and then vote these people
out vote out the liars
[Music]
thank you